good morning welcome to the wolf
technology conference my name is Lou
D'Andrea and this morning Peter faloona
and I will be taking a first look at
some new technology we've been working
on wolf for alpha notebooks I'm here to
represent the notebook side and I think
it's safe to say that Peters here to
represent the Wolfram Alpha side and
you've all done your due diligence and
read the abstracts so I won't go through
this you saw Steven demo it yesterday as
part of his talk so I won't I won't go
too much into that but I would like to
give you a basis all right now we're on
I would like to give you a basis of
where we have been in the past for
Wolfram Alpha notebooks for Wolfram
Alpha support and where we're going so
let's take a look at so we have these
these two wonderful technologies we've
had Mathematica now for 30 odd years
we've had Wolfram Alpha for what five
seven ten years something like that and
there have been ways to communicate back
and forth between them so one of the
things we did when we first developed
both form alpha is we built this nice
REST API there's a web service you can
access this REST API well for wolfram
mathematica access this Web API
initially we built out a way to get full
Wolfram Alpha results exactly you know
mimicking the website experience in
Mathematica so you could type the equal
sign twice to get into this mode where
you get full results and you evaluate
this I don't think this is going to be
surprised anybody you get sort of a full
assemblage of what you might see on the
website
the one difference well one of the
interesting differences is that these
the contents of this sandwich of pods in
Mathematica well on the web is just a
bunch of gifts right and some links
other things in Mathematica these are
native cells so for an example as simple
as this perhaps that's not so useful but
for more complex examples where you
might have images being returned 3d
graphics being returned
or other interesting cells being
returned like manipulates so here's an
example where we have a 3d plot on the
web this just sits there doing nothing
in Mathematica now you can move this
around and here's an example where the
actual web results could contain
manipulates and they don't contain
manipulates directly on the web yet but
when delivering these things to
Mathematica they certainly can and do
and this is all well and good the
getting a multi-headed thing back as a
result isn't all that useful getting
this sort of monolithic thing back what
what you might want is just a single
piece of Wolfram language code or a
single subpod if you like so we built
out a way to do that too when you press
equal only once you get into this mode
where you're where you get not this full
collection of pods you just get a single
thing this turned out to be incredibly
useful and it's one of the key things
that we're basing the Wolfram notebook
concept on we also have this kind of
inline syntax helper where you type you
hold on the control key and you press
equal and you get a mode where a bit of
language can be translated directly to a
bit of natural language can be
translated directly to a bit of Wolfram
language so here we have you know
because there are plenty of places in
the product as syntax grows and grows
and grows our memories unfortunately
don't so I can't possibly keep in mind
all of the entities syntaxes or the
quantity syntaxes or all of these things
so it's it's convenient to have very
nearby a product that can do that
remembering for me and just look up you
know you type the natural language and
then you get the Wolfram language thing
out of it and it automatically goes and
does the right thing okay
so that's that's kind of where we were
in version 8 when Wolfram Alpha was
first released all of the previous
technologies that you've just seen are
based on the Wolfram Alpha function
which is sort of the the API connector
it's the thing that actually goes off to
the web
service and and grabs pieces of the pod
content right so that was the direction
of using Wolfram Alpha from Mathematica
we also have a way currently on Wolfram
Alpha calm to lead users into the
Mathematica infrastructure people who
otherwise wouldn't know about
Mathematica they go to the web they see
you know some query results and when we
get this pod content if you hover over
one of the pods you get a sequence of
controls these controls many of the
controls are leading people back into
the Wolfram ecosystem so the Data button
gives you I think that might only be
available for Wolfram Alpha Pro users
but it gives you choices to to grab
notebook content other formatted content
data behind the behind a particular
result the plain text link often gives
you the Wolfram language the Wolfram
language translation corresponding to
this particular pod interactivity gives
you a pre generated sort of can notebook
of content that might contain
manipulates or other things downloaded
that you can download to your machine
and the open code button over on the
side here gives you a direct version of
a notebook that you can open instantly
in cloud and this takes you to cloud and
opens a notebook for you with your query
sort of pre-populated but all these
things are are you know we we we are
guessing what you want based on the one
query and the one piece of information
we have so what is Wolfram Alpha
notebooks welcome alpha notebooks is our
attempt to give you the power of the
notebook interface but the simplicity of
just typing queries by default
let me demonstrate what I'm talking
about so so we have we have the concept
here is that Wolfram Alpha notebooks we
want something where when you just type
currently in notebooks when you just
type you get inputs you get Wolfram
language inputs and a Wolfram Alpha
notebook you just type you get a Wolfram
Alpha query what happens when you
evaluate that query
well that
was off and sort of the single equal
mode and tries to get a single Wolfram
language expression corresponding to
that query and then evaluate that
expression in your notebook but it does
have all the power of the Wolfram Alpha
infrastructures such as assumptions so
that you can choose
you know how to disambiguate your query
assumptions is also the way the API
delivers formulas so all of the
wolframalpha.com queries that bring up
formulas are going to work in Wolfram
Alpha notebooks one other interesting
thing that we've that we've been working
on are the ability to provide input
suggestions in addition to output
suggestions so let me let me demonstrate
what that is for people who may not know
so they're turned on here so let me
switch over to a different version of
Mathematica so here we have No okay well
I won't try that then so we have we have
always had the ability to produce
predictions based on the Wolfram
language on your Wolfram language
session so you type an input you get an
output and then you get this stripe that
some of you may have turned off because
this annoying stripe you know I know
what I want to do I'm an experienced
Wolfram language programmer I don't need
you telling me what what I can can and
can't do that's fine for experience
Wolfram language programmers but for
people who are new to the Wolfram
ecosystem maybe not even Wolfram
language knowledgeable at all you know
it's it's a very useful thing and we've
developed some interesting and
interesting extension of this so let's
do a sample query by the way this is a
wolf alpha notebook as you've already
seen just typing into this notebook
produces this orange frame cell this is
a Wolfram query cell a natural language
input cell and evaluating this cell is
going to go off to the server so if we
have good why
by here I'm going to go after the server
and grab a couple of things so I want to
point out a couple of things here before
I turn over the rest of this talk to
Peter I want to point out that so we
have the query we have the first thing
under the query as I mentioned we have
access to all the wool from all of the
WolframAlpha disambiguation features so
all the assumptions that you would see
on the website for this query are here
the next stripe our input predictions so
input predictions are the things that
you know I guess on the web these would
be called related queries but these are
things that can happen entirely in your
own client session so we have I don't
know a handful of of these guys they
plot function and integral that sounds
interesting so this goes off and takes a
look at the query that you ran and the
result that it provided and then reruns
a new query with the corresponding
Wolfram language inputs and goes off and
creates more predictions for them and
gives you the result note that you're
building up a session here in your
Wolfram Alpha notebook without needing
to type a single line of Wolfram
language code all you needed to do is
start typing in the notebook and of
course there's lots of interesting
things that we could present as outputs
for various queries and that's one of
the things that I think Peter is now
going to to show the the sort of range
of things that can be done and some of
the more interesting features that we've
envisioned for the Wolfram Alpha
notebooks project Peter so I've got a
new click here with a bunch of examples
kind of ready to go to illustrate a few
things I think Lou's actually covered
some of them so I might be doing a
little bit of skipping so first the
interactive results I think John
mentioned in his talk earlier that the
CDF plugin for browsers is not available
for some time though and that's a pity
because a lot of inputs that have been
supported for a long time and move
malphur actually cater
and results they're interactive so
something like this by me yeah yeah
enough
all right cool so yeah so results like
this like a plot with parameter in the
argument of the plot that you want the
very sort of brings up manipulate
expression and then this in in a wolf's
mouth a new book this is just a regular
manipulated object that you can play
around with and as we said as well
there's a lot of who've mouthful results
where the result itself is not
interactive it's in this case it's an
integral of something that gives a
number but if you look at the fugu from
alpha I put and you can see that spiky
that I just clicked on is the equivalent
of double equals and a regular notebook
and some of the other pods in the result
can be interactive so here's a a Riemann
sum for the integral so it's a bunch of
rectangles that approximate the integral
and you can vary this you can change the
midpoint and so on so all of this
interactivity can it comes back to life
when you're working in a booth Mouse or
notebook the next thing is getting other
inputs so I think we mentioned to you
that the thing of often with an input
and move now for some some part of the
input is ambiguous in some way so Paris
is usually Paris France but can also be
Paris Texas or even Paris Illinois might
be from there here slightly smaller city
but yeah so that's available and and
it's interesting that that isn't
available when you do single equals in
regular notebook so this is kind of a
useful feature to have here input
suggestions again luminescent this are
just very quickly sooo this when you do
some kind of input in this case it's
going to be an integral there's a sort
of a heuristic that runs that looks at
the integrator and sees that it's you
know it's an integrator of a symbolic
expression so it suggests a bunch of
things that are likely to be of interest
so you know you can plot function so on
and finally also the example pages that
are on the web can be accessed from the
wolf's mouth or notebook here so we're
like plot example page and what what it
does is it brings up a new will
a notebook with all those examples that
would be normally seen on the web you
can school sue and find and evaluate at
your leisure so okay so yeah one of the
more popular features on the website is
step by step solutions for homework and
such things so these are available here
again there's a heuristic that looks I
think it's looking at the input here to
decide that this is something that's
likely to have step-by-step solutions so
you click on this it generates a new
input and gives you the step by step
solutions from mu from alpha
okay so formulas and calculators so
formulas as again we mentioned they are
available in move malphur and when you
run a query for a formula where you
haven't specified any numerical values
you just get this interface here to let
you specify so you know I can vary
whatever I wanted the value it click on
equals and it will go back to MU from
alpha and give you the result with those
parameters substituted and the result is
the object that's returned here's a
formula theater expression and just also
evaluate these but just you can quickly
see that if you I seen you in advance
the parameters you wanted to substitute
you could you could have included them
in your query and you wouldn't get the
the interface for that if you don't know
the formula at all you can just enter a
bunch of quantities and the formula
parser AXI gusu and looks up whatever
formulas actually fit with those
quantities and returns everything that
those who hear there's Ohm's law there's
also the power voltage-current
relationship and you just get a list of
the results and so similar to formulas
are calculators so the idea with the
calculator is whenever you know you want
to do you know what you want to do but
you don't know what exactly to do it
with so you know integrals derivatives
limits all these kind of things have
these kind of calculator interfaces and
so these are all available as well
similarly for plots so if you wanted to
plot something you don't know exactly
what and you can see that you get
various optional fields that you can
substitute so here I you know I've got a
plots I can vary the range and the
variable so this is kind of as a
workflow it's kind of you know Pleakley
for like a classroom type environment
where you know the topic of the day
might be differentiation or whatever you
can just bring up one of these and then
just evaluate away to sort of see how
things work so just quickly the two two
features that we're still kind of
working on that are going to be key to
this new book sort of workflow are the
ability to define variables in natural
language so it's it's all very well if
you know exactly what you want to do you
can do it all them online but usually
the way things are done in the notebook
is you define a bunch of intermediate
things so here I'm just going to define
in a very kind of contrived example you
know just building up to expanding a
polynomial here so not too surprising
but this kind of the ability to define
things like this will be quite useful
and also the ability to clear and remove
symbols is also similarly output
references so everyone who uses Wolfram
language knows 8 minus n or percentage n
as the way of referring to your previous
results we've made that work here as
well but for people who don't know about
that syntax we've also got sort of more
natural language support so if you
somehow get a function and then decide
you want to differentiate that function
something like differentiate this will
evaluate and give you the percentage
there integrate the above you get back
to where you started will work in the
same way so we've got a bunch of these
kind of natural language linguistics for
sort of you know hinting to the to the
wolf's mouth for parse if you want to
refer to a previous result and similarly
graphics work the same kind of things
work for graphics and this is quite
useful if you you know you want to plot
something and then you want to adjust
various aspects of the plot so you you
know in this case just adding a
background so you know make the
background like gray and above it knows
that the above means the previous plot
so on and so the same kind of things can
be done for images but I think we're
cruising time so just skip the image
example and just finally I'm not sure if
I think Steven might have done this in
his talk but the fact that you have
moved from language here in the output
for people who actually are curious or
who are getting to know the language
they can actually start to edit this so
this is just a silly example where you
know I wanted to do some kind of
manipulate but the default ranges that
we choose in the manipulate were very
useful so I can adjust those I can
adjust the limit of the variable so
let's see right so what this example
just trying to show you the interference
of sine waves with slightly different
frequencies and so that kind of you get
this kind of phenomenon but you know
obviously this would have been quite
annoying to have to go back and keep you
know modifying and making the input
string longer and longer so it's it's
useful to be able to edit that Wilson
language code okay so that's the end of
my examples who's going to quickly go
back to the notebook and just summarize
so Wolfram Alpha notebooks who they for
I think as we've ended so far it's it's
for people who are familiar with smooth
from alpha but not very familiar with
the poofing language and it's giving
news users a much more rich environment
in which to work so all the benefits of
working in a notebook and with you know
the formatting and so on and we as I
also said I think it's a useful stepping
stones of the roof language because you
get the output in movement language form
it's sort of you know curious users are
going to start to play around with that
and get to see how it works and we think
it's particularly this will be useful
for classroom type environments
you know like high-school students who
have never done any programming
potentially your very little will be
able to start doing real calculations in
natural language so in terms of
availability it's going to be it's going
to be a document type in Mathematica and
also in the Wolfram Cloyd and also a
standalone product again geared at sort
of classroom type markets so just yeah
finally if anyone's interested and has
ideas and suggestions we love to hear
it's still very much on the development
so I think with that oh thanks
[Applause]